Transcriber: leena Bassam
المدقّق: Christin Melad
السَّلامُ عَلَيْكُمْ
بدايةً، عندما نكون في محفل مثل هذه المحافل
التي تتحدث عن التطوع ومجالات التطوع،
دائمًا ما تكون في الأذهان صورة كيف نتطوع؟
ولماذا نتطوع؟ وفيما نتطوع؟
لكن هل سألنا أنفسنا السؤال الذي يقول من
يتطوع؟ من يمكنه أن يتطوع لدينا في المجتمع؟
ما الصورة التي في أذهاننا؟ من يتطوع؟
من سيكون متطوع؟
دائمًا تكون لدينا صورة مُحددة
أو كما نقول صورة ذهنية نمطية،
تقول أن من يتطوع دائمًا لا بد أن يكون
في سن مُعين في قدرة بدنية معينة،
أيضًا في كما نقول صحة جيدة.
لكن ماذا لو قلنا ذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة؟
هل نظرنا في إمكانية أن يكونوا
جزءًا من فريقنا التطوعي؟
هل ترون أنهم سيبذلون وسيقدمون لنا؟
بالتأكيد نعم.
ما دام أن كما نقول ميثاق حقوق الإنسان
لذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة،
تحددت الإتفاقية
على أن ذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة
لا بد أن نوفر لهم تكافؤ الفرص،
لا بد أن نمنحهم المساواة،
لا بد أن يكونون فعلاً جزء فعال
في المجتمع وجزء من كياننا
حتى يكونوا كما نقول
شريك في التنمية المُستدامة.
فما دام أن كما نقول كفل لهم الحق في أن
يكون لهم فرص وظيفية،
لهم إمكانية في أن يقدموا للمجتمع .
ماذا لو كانوا في مجال التطوع؟
بالتأكيد ستكون لديهم الكثير من الفرص.
لكن هل نحن مكّناهم؟
هل نحن منحناهم هذه الفرص؟
لا بد أن نلتفت لهذه الفئة التي كما نقول
تشكل ما لا يقل عن 7%
من سكان المملكة العربية السعودية.
فلو نظرنا في إمكانية تمكينهم،
لإستطعنا أن نمكّنهم في الكثير من المجالات،
سواء مكّناهم بدنيًا من أعمال مكتبية،
مجالات الترجمة ومجالات النسخ
ومجالات الضيافة.
أيضًا لديهم القدرة أن يتطوعوا ذهنيًا،
إن كان لدينا في مجال الترجمة،
في مجال البرمجة.
نحن كأفراد أصّحاء نتمايز فيما بيننا البعض
في القدرة العقلية وفي القدرة البدنية.
أيضًا ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
قد سُلبت منهم بعض الإصابات،
لكنهم في المقابل لديهم طاقات
بشرية لا بد أن نستثمرها.
ورؤية المملكة ركزت على هذا الجانب،
لا بد أن نستثمر القوة البشرية
أيًا كانت دون التمييز.
نعلم أن في العالم أجمع لدينا قضية محاربة
التمييز أيًا كان، سواء تمييز الجندرية
عندما نتحدث عن الجنس،
كذلك تمييز عن العرق وتمييز اللون.
أيضًا عندما نميز الآن
بين الصحيح وبين السقيم،
هذا أيضًا يعتبر إنتهاك
ولا نكون نخوض هذا المجال.
فأيضًا عندما كان لدي قراءة في
إتفاقية الأمم المتحدة لحقوق الإنسان،
تحدث عن ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة أن أيضًا
مفهومهم لا بد أن يُغيّر من أذهاننا.
بمعنى، نحن الآن عندما نقول شخص مُعاق
ماذا أعني بالمُعاق؟
أن تكون لديه إصابة.
لكن ماذا قالت ميثاق الأمم المتحدة؟
تحدثت عن أمر آخر،
قالت لابد أن نطور هذا المفهوم،
فالإعاقة ليست الإصابة التي أُصيب بها ذلك
الفرد، ربما كان قد وُلد صحيحًا،
ولكنه تعرض إلى حادث خارجي.
لكن يقول أن العوائق ما هي؟
هي المواقف أو الحواجز الذي يصطدم بها
ذلك الشخص حتى يدخل إلى المجتمع.
نحن لا بد أن نمكّنهم بأن نكسر
هذه الحواجز.
حتى أن الأمم المتحدة قالت لا بد أن نُغيّر
هذا المفهوم النَّمَطي السائد بين الجميع.
العوائق ليست بهم ذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة،
بل العوائق كما نقول المواقف أو الحواجز
التي وضعناها فيما بيننا البعض.
فلو مكّناهم لوجدنا لهم الكثير من الفرص.
أيضًا، رؤية المملكة 2030 عندما ركزت في
برنامج جودة الحياة وبرنامج الوصول الشامل،
كان برنامج جودة الحياة والوصول الشامل
ركز على ما يتعلق بذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة.
لو نظرنا إلى برنامج الوصول الشامل
كان يتحدث عن قضية التمكين،
بأن نُدمج ذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة في جميع
المجالات التي يمكن أن يعطوا ويبذلوا بها.
إن تحدثنا عن برنامج جودة الحياة،
سيدخل في نطاق الرعاية،
أي نرعاهم ونهيئ لهم المرافق
ونهيئ فرص تطوعية لخدمتهم
حتى يكونوا قادرين
أن يندمجوا لدينا في المجتمع.
إذًا لو نظرنا
كيف نتطوع لأجلهم؟
عندما قرأت الإحصائية الأخيرة
للمملكة العربية السعودية،
ذكرت أنهم يشكلون 7% من السكان،
وكانت الإعاقة البصرية تُشَّكل
800 ألف شخص مصاب في المملكة بإعاقة بصرية.
إذًا هذا المعاق بصريًا ماذا سيحتاج؟
لديه الرغبة بأن يقرأ
ولديه الرغبة بأن يتعلم.
إذًا ماذا سنضيف له نحن؟ ماذا نتطوع؟
أعتقد أن هذا الجانب
يحتاج أن نُثري مكتبة كاملة،
حتى لا نقول يقرؤون، حتى يبصرون الكتب،
حتى يبصرون النتاج المعرفي
الذي هو بين أيدينا.
فكانت فكرتي أو عفوًا تجربتي البسيطة
كما نقول في مرحلة إعداد رسالتي الدكتوراه،
كانت لدي خطة بعد أن أنتهي من الدكتوراه
لا بد أن أخدم، لا بد أن استثمر وقتي،
لا بد أن أخرج قليلاً والتفت إلى المجتمع
ماذا يحتاج؟
بدايةً بحكم تخصصي للغة العربية،
كان لديَّ هدف بأن أنشُر اللغة العربية.
بمعنى أُعلم الحرف العربي
للكثير من المسلمين،
الجاليات جدًا أعدادهم كبيرة في الشركات
والمؤسسات يتمنون من يعلمهم حرفًا عربيًا.
فكانت بدايةً هذا الهدف الذي بيدي
وكما نقول أُصمم حقيبة تدريبية.
لكن شاءت الظروف أن تتحول،
وكانت حينها انتشرت كما نقول ظاهرة
كورونا، أُغلقت الأبواب علينا في المنازل،
كان أمامي فقط خيار واحد أن أفتح منصة العمل
التطوعي، استثمر وقتي وأنا في داخل المنزل.
التعليم تحول عن بُعد والعمل عن بُعد،
فكانت الفرصة أن أفتح منصة العمل التطوعي.
كانت فيها العديد من الفرص،
الكثير يحتاج وجميع النطاقات تحتاج،
أيًا كانت تلك النطاقات.
لكن أنا وقفت على حالة وجدتها أنها
حالة إنسانية تحتاج فعلاً منا أن نتكاتف.
كانت هي فتاة من فاقدي البصر مكفوفة
تحتاج أن تتعلم وتحتاج أن تدرس
لكن ليست لديها المادة العلمية.
فكانت هذه القضية هي التي دفعتني
لا بد أن نتطوع من أجل هذه الفتاة.
تواصلت حينها مع رئيس جمعية ذوي الإعاقة
الذي طرح تلك الفرصة،
أبلغني أن الحالة فعلاً إنسانية عاجلة،
الطالبة تحتاج أن تتعلم
لكن لا تتوفر لديها المصادر المعرفية.
فكانت الفكرة الجميلة أيضًا،
الكتاب لم يكن أي كتاب بل كان يرتبط
بتاريخ المملكة العربية السعودية،
نحن سنقدم إضافة نوعية
ليس فقط أن الطالبة ستتعلم،
بل هذا الكتاب سيضاف إلى مكتبة مكفوفي البصر
تُقدم لهم تاريخ المملكة العربية السعودية
الأولى والثانية والثالثة،
فكان يعني لامس جانب إنساني جدًا كبير،
أن هناك من تحتاج أن تُبصر،
تحسسنا حاجة تلك الفتاة،
فتقاسمنا ذلك الكتاب وتكاتفت الجهود
وأنجزناه تقريبًا في أقل من أسبوع،
قمنا بتحويله إلى كتاب بلغة برايل،
واستطاعت الفتاة أن تتعلم وتدرس
ولم تكن تلك الإعاقة
كما نقول عقبة أمامها حتى تُكمل.
فهنا لو نظرنا إلى هذا العمل
ربما هو عمل جدًا بسيط
لم يكلفني من وقتي الكثير ربما بجهاز الحاسب
ونحن بين أهالينا قد أعددنا ذلك الكتاب،
لكن هذا الكتاب ماذا كان يعني؟
الكتاب هذا كان يعني حياة بالنسبة للفتاة.
الفتاة أبصرت،
الفتاة استطاعت أن تقرأ.
فكانت تجربتي في إعداد كتاب لغة برايل
هو إضافة إنسانية لامست فيَّ الكثير.
وجدت أنني لا استصغر من المعروف
ما أستطيع أن أقدم للآخرين،
مهما كان المعروف الذي بيدك
لا تستصغره للآخرين،
ربما الجزء البسيط الذي نحن لا نراه شيئًا،
قد يعني حياة بالنسبة للآخرين.
قد يضيف لهم قيمة معرفية.
أيضًا مجالات التطوع لو حاولنا أن نتكاتف
ربما هذا الجانب يحتاج جدًا منا اهتمام،
أن نُثري فعلاً المكتبة العربية
بكتب بلغة برايل.
هم لهم الحق بأن يمارسوا هواياتهم،
لهم الحق بأن يتعلموا،
لكن من يُقدم؟ أعتقد أنه عمل جدًا بسيط على
جهاز الحاسوب لم يأخذ من وقتي الكثير،
لكنه سيضيف لهم القيمة المعرفية الكبيرة
وسيجعلهم يبصرون ويتحسسون من العلم
الذي نحن ننهل منه ونستفيد منه.
ماذا عَلَّمنِي التطوع؟
عَلَّمنِي التطوع أن العطاء لا حدود له.
نستطيع أن نعطي جميع الأشخاص
دون إستثناء بين جنسهم وعِرْقُهم،
أيضًا دون إستثناء بين صحتهم وسَّقْمُهم.
أيضًا عَلَّمنِي أن العمل إنساني
هو منبع الرحمة،
نرحم الآخرين ونتحسس حاجاتهم،
يكون أيضًا سمة للتكافل والتكامل الاجتماعي.
أيضًا عَلَّمنِي أن ذوي الإحتياجات الخاصة
هم جزء من كيان المجتمع،
هم طاقة بشرية أيضًا لها الحق بأن تتطوع،
وأيضًا نتلمس حاجاتهم ونتطوع لأجلهم.
أيضًا عَلَّمنِي أنه يُرْأبُ صدعًا
ويسد فجوة كبيرة في المجتمع الإنساني،
وأيضًا يبني مجتمعًا،
وبه تنهض اقتصادات الأمم.
جميع الأمم التي نهضت الآن
كما تُسمى العالم الأول،
جميعهم كانوا يبنون، وكما نقول يعوّلون
كثيرًا على الشباب، لديهم الطاقات البشرية.
وأن كما نقول المتطوع
هو جزء كبير من البناء المجتمعي.
أيضًا عَلَّمنِي معنى الإنسان.
والسَّلامُ عَلَيْكُمْ وَرَحْمَةُ اللَّهِ.